in 20th century women your character
lies a lot and I was curious that's
that's that's one of her traits that she
lies a lot is that is that something
that comes easily for you seem like
you'd be a very honest person yes I mean
yes because Julia my character that she
hides a lot of things she has a lot of
different sides to her and keep things
hidden and stuff I I think I'm a pretty
honest person I when I do burr a lot
because I don't drive I have my license
but I'm just kind of scared to drive it
it's really it's perfect yes it's great
so I her a lot and I feel like it's I
don't know it's interesting because also
they don't know my name because it's not
on the account at someone else's like
right where your privacy you don't put
Elle Fanning down yeah they said they
don't know who I am
and I just find that fascinating so I go
in I kind of make up careers or like
stories to tell the Cooper driver so I
totally just like live them and I got in
the uber like the other day and the guy
was you know who's talking about his
kids and like his marital problems and
he's like oh well you have kids don't
you and I was like yeah I have two kids
I have a boy and a girl
this goes on I've been like a
professional volleyball player before to
the uber drivers so they just have get
to create these scenarios yeah I just
lied to them yeah you're an idea yeah
sociopath
I've lost all my money you have to help
me I kind of that I could see how it'd
be fun for you to kind of escape a
little bit be someone else
you